esperan desde el amanecer con
recipientes en la mano en busca de unos
litros de combustible escenas que se han
convertido en el día a día de misiones
de celan de ses enfadados con su
presidente y el gobierno quien sufre
quien está esperando en las colas somos
nosotros el pueblo no nuestros políticos
casi siete millones de personas votamos
para que llegaran al poder no me
importan los partidos políticos todos
los diputados deben dimitir
inmediatamente ninguno de ellos es
confiable a pesar de las horas de espera
no todos podrán abastecerse en pocas
horas esta gasolinera se queda sin
combustible
no es la primera vez que esto ocurre
ayer ya vine para nada tengo que comprar
gasolina para los mini buzos de mi
empresa de transporte sin eso cómo puedo
ganarme la vida para tener ingresos
necesito combustible lo sabríamos si
nuestros vehículos funcionarán con agua
una escasez sin precedentes en la
historia de stri lanka la falta de
productos de primera necesidad se agrava
cada día en las tiendas muchos productos
desaparecieron y estanterías y esto sin
mencionar la inflación de los precios
hasta un
25% para algunos alimentos
nos hemos quedado sin leche en polvo
hace 2 meses nuestras estanterías
estaban llenas pero esto es todo lo que
nos queda un kilo de lentejas pasó de 30
centavos a 1.50 euros en pocas semanas
lo más preocupante es que también falta
medicamentos varios hospitales están sin
anestesia y han tenido que suspender
algunas intervenciones quirúrgicas en
esta clínica infantil las reservas se
encuentran ahora limitadas según varios
expertos internacionales tri la ncaa
está al borde del impago el gobierno ha
anunciado que va a pedir ayuda al fondo
monetario internacional- se espera que
las negociaciones para reestructurar su
deuda de 46 mil millones de euros
comiencen la próxima semana